hey hola solo quería hacer este breve
vídeo para introducirte a lo que es
probablemente de hecho definitivamente
es el mayor cambio que hemos hecho en la
historia de lacan academy hemos
introducido un nuevo flujo de
aprendizaje que pretende enganchar a más
gente hemos oído de muchos de nuestros
usuarios que hay muchísimo contenido en
la canaca de mí que de hecho no sabían
por dónde empezar no sabían cuál era el
nivel más apropiado para ellos así que
hemos invertido bastante tiempo pensando
acerca en acerca de esto y lo que quiero
que veas justamente en este momento es
nuestro nuevo flujo de aprendizaje así
que digamos que soy un usuario nuevo eso
me da un muy bonito y lindo mensaje de
bienvenida y le digo genial exploremos
cuando entramos verás esta misión que es
el mundo de las matemáticas y justo
ahora que vamos empezando es la única
misión que tenemos esencialmente
atraviesa todos los ejercicios de
matemáticas que hemos desarrollado en la
cana academy y en los próximos meses
verás otras misiones misiones enfocadas
a distintos grados de nivel misiones
enfocadas para que te prepares para un
examen misiones diseñadas para que seas
capaz de hacer algún tipo de proyecto
también verás algunas misiones de otras
materias ahora en estos cuadritos que
ves estos quizás al para los que ya
estén familiarizados con el mapa del
conocimiento pueden verlo como un mapa
del conocimiento condensado para alguna
misión muy en particular que estés
pensando digamos aquí tenemos 482
cajitas de hecho cada una de éstas
representa una habilidad y representa
cierto tipo de problemas de matemáticas
así que lo que vamos a hacer ahora lo
que voy a hacer ahora es empezar la
prueba y yo te recomiendo que lo hagas
también porque es bastante divertido
vamos a empezar la prueba y esto es
esencialmente para responder a aquella
pregunta de dónde debo empezar en la
canaca de mí qué ejercicios son los más
apropiados para mí así que vamos a tomar
justo ahora la pre prueba vamos a
empezarlo
ok y por supuesto aquí en la pre prueba
si yo veo algo que es completamente
desconocido para mí que a lo mejor hasta
podrías asustarme simplemente debo
decirle no he aprendido esto aún ok
entonces una vez que está esto entendido
nos dice si sabemos que el ángulo azul
mide 140 y 8 grados
cuál es la medida del ángulo anaranjado
y en realidad como son ángulos opuestos
por el vértice miden lo mismo y son 148
muy bien ahora cuál es el área del
cuadrado vamos a suponer que yo no he
visto nada no sé de área sobre
rectángulos así que le voy a poner que
no he aprendido esto y realmente esta es
una prueba adaptativa si respondo algo
bien me va a poner problemas más
complicados o de temas más avanzados si
tengo respuestas mal me va a mandar
temas más básicos o más simples que el
número podría reemplazar este simbolito
de aquí y en realidad esto es una
proporción así que tenemos que 6 por 6
son 36
pensémoslo al revés 36 entre 6 son 6 18
entre 6 son 3 muy bien así que aquí me
dice que me falta realizar 5 problemas
más como puedes ver es un poquito largo
pero dice mueve el punto anaranjado a
tres cuartos en la recta numérica y tres
cuartos es un cuarto menos que uno así
que vamos a andar por aquí vamos a
enviar nuestra respuesta
y acelerando un poquito todo este
proceso me dice que el número podría
reemplazar este simbolito de aquí abajo
tenemos 8 más 19 es igual a simbolito
más uno más 9
ok aquí puedo decir cuál es la respuesta
de hecho la respuesta es 8 pero vamos a
suponer para fines de nuestro argumento
que a lo mejor yo no sea un bien de la
propiedad asociativa de la suma así que
le voy a poner que aún no he aprendido
esto y ya hemos terminado la pre prueba
ahora el sistema está construyendo un
modelo de qué es lo que más o menos sé y
qué es lo que no sé digo realmente es
una aproximación de lo que probablemente
podría saber ok una vez que hemos
terminado puedes ver que ya los
cuadritos han cambiado de color algunos
de ellos por ejemplo los cuadritos
grises son aquellos que no he practicado
mientras que los cuadritos azules son
los que el sistema cree que ya sé ya
tengo conocimiento de eso al menos hasta
cierto nivel ok y mientras más oscuro
sea el color azul significa que dominó
mucho mejor el tema así que vamos
para mirar estos cuadritos por ejemplo
aquí me dice me falta practicar
graficando sistemas de desigualdades
pero me dice que si se ejes de simetría
también me dice que se restas de un
dígito entonces como puedes ver los
conceptos que he practicado están ya en
azul y si por ejemplo le picamos algunos
de estos cuadritos directamente me manda
los ejercicios que puedo realizar de ese
tema inmediatamente puedo ir a esos
ejercicios y esto realmente es una clave
de todo esto si tuviéramos en vez de
tener la vieja versión de lacan academy
ahora ya tenemos este mapa del
conocimiento enorme en donde puede uno
decir ah se me ocurre qué debo hacer
algunos ejercicios de estos 500
cuadritos déjame ver quizás debería
empezar con el plano complejo y bueno
tenemos muchísimos ejercicios así que
aquí abajo me va a recomendar
inmediatamente algunas que considere el
sistema que yo debería seguir así que
por ejemplo en vez de hacer leyendo
gráficos
y voy a hacer esto de problemas o
fracciones en la recta numérica vamos a
practicar las fracciones en la recta
numérica y directamente me manda a esos
ejercicios así que inmediatamente ya
estamos en las fracciones y me dice
mueve el punto anaranjado a tres sextos
en la recta numérica y esto ya está
dividida dividido perdón en sextos pues
nos movemos a tres sextos comprobamos la
respuesta y me dice que lo hice bien y
además me dice que tengo que hacer
55 ejercicios correctos en una sola
sentada y además estuviera yo confundido
puedo poner este vídeo de aquí que me va
a explicar más o menos cómo es que debo
trabajar este tipo de ejercicio así que
vamos a seguir explorando qué es lo que
tenemos de nuevo en nuestro sistema y
déjame comentarte que si tú eres un
tutor o tienes un tutor más bien el
tutor en realidad a través de todas las
herramientas que ya hemos desarrollado
puede llevar un muy buen rastreo de qué
es en lo que están trabajando sus
alumnos de esta forma el tutor puede
hacer una recomendación de los
ejercicios en los cuales deben
cárcel oa cuales debe darle cierta
prioridad ahora ya que lleves cierto
tiempo en estos asuntos
verás que tu panel de conocimiento
lucirá poco a poco de esta forma cada
vez se va a ir llenando de cuadritos
cada vez más azules y más oscuras y el
lugar en donde puedes ir haciendo que
esto se vaya rellenando cada vez más es
en esta sección que dice tenemos un
desafío a tu de estrés así que voy a
empezar uno de estos ésta es la
herramienta que vas a usar repetidamente
para poder llegar a tu objetivo de
llenar toda la tabla por ejemplo
empezamos y me dice dados estos estos
dos segmentos que son ortogonales el
ángulo cbb es igual a 7 x + 14 y el
ángulo ave x es 3 x menos 4 encuentra el
ángulo cb de cvd así que pues
esencialmente como estos dos o más 90 lo
único que tenemos que hacer es sumar
estos dos que son 10 x + 10 son 90 lo
cual me dice que
x 1 debe ser 9 por lo tanto x debe ser 8
y como queremos el ángulo cb de el
ángulo cvd es este y como x es 8 tenemos
7 x 856 + 14 56 más 14 me parece que son
70 lo cual es cierto y hay que hacer en
realidad cinco problemas por ejemplo
podemos hacer esta división vamos a
decirle que aún no le v no lo he
aprendido me dice que haga esto así que
podemos hacer esa suma vamos a hacerlo
más rápido y decirle que no he aprendido
y vamos a simplificar esta expresión
esto así es sencillo esto es menos 6
menos q son menos 7 cubo vamos a poner
menos 7 cv y hay que sumarle tres así
que comprobamos la respuesta y estuvo
perfecto aquí empieza a hacer toda la
carga de puntos y cómo te das cuenta
empieza inmediatamente según el tipo de
ejercicios a cambiar el color de nuestra
tabla muy bien entonces este flujo de
aprendizaje realmente asegura que
debemos saber muy bien dónde empezar y
dónde poder aprender cosas nuevas
tenemos una gran oportunidad también de
revisar aquellas cosas que ya hemos
estudiado pero que bueno siempre es
bueno tenerlo en mente así que espero
verlos próximamente llenando todo su
mapa del conocimiento llenándolo de sus
habilidades y cumpliendo la misión del
mundo de las matemáticas y de las
futuras misiones que vamos a ir subiendo
y realmente quiero escuchar de ustedes
me gustaría mucho escuchar de ustedes
todos sus comentarios y que nos den todo
toda la retroalimentación que puedan
para hacer de esta experiencia mucho
mejor realmente los invito a que vengan
a esta sección de sugerencias y que le
den en el botón de dejar comentarios y
nos digan qué es lo que piensan aunque
nos digan que si les está funcionando si
no les está funcionando y si tienen
mejores ideas que podrían hacer de esto
mucho mejor por favor háganoslo saber